hallo aus Kassel hier hinter mir im
uhlenspiegel treffe ich gleich drei
Leute die mir jeder ein Thema Mitbringen
von dem sie sagen da muss ich in Hessen
ganz dringend was ändern Wirtschaft
Zuwanderung soziale Ungerechtigkeit
welche Fragen muss die kommende
Landtagswahl beantworten die kneipenwahl
richtet den Blick auf drei politische
Themen die das Leben von jungen Menschen
in Hessen unmittelbar beeinflussen ich
wünsche mir dass ich in der Schule
beigebracht bekomme wie kann ich meine
Potenziale entfalten wie kann ich
Verantwortung übernehmen ich bin hier
weil die hessische Landesregierung immer
noch viel zu wenig für den Klimaschutz
in Hessen macht wir sind momentan vom
Aussterben bedroht für junge Landwirte
und wir kleinen landwirtschaftlichen
Betriebe
[Musik]
der kneipenrad entscheidet in
demokratischer Manier welches Thema ich
genauer recherchieren werde bei meiner
anschließenden Reise durch hessen will
ich das Thema aus ganz verschiedenen
Perspektiven beleuchten und hoffentlich
besser verstehen wo die Stellschrauben
liegen und wer darauf wie ein Fluss
nehmen kann
mein Name ist Eva und ich bin hier weil
ihr alle darüber entscheiden sollt
welches Thema dieser Film hier bekommt
und das hier sind unsere drei
Kandidatinnen Emma aus Kassel Jana
ebenfalls aus Kassel und Torben aus
Weilmünster schön dass Ihr da seid jeder
von euch hat gleich 1 Minute Zeit um uns
von eurem Thema eurer Geschichte zu
überzeugen und anschließend dürft ihr
abstimmen immer du bist die erste und
ich würde sagen deine Minute startet
jetzt hi ich bin Emma 17 und komme hier
aus Kassel mache nächstes Jahr Abi und
eigentlich wünsche ich mir von meiner
Schule Laufbahn genau das Gegenteil wie
es jetzt gerade passiert ich wünsche mir
dass ich in der Schule beigebracht
bekomme wie kann ich meine Potenziale
entfalten wie kann ich Verantwortung
übernehmen wie er lerne ich neues wissen
doch dass es nicht Realität Realität ist
dass wir eine fehlende Ausstattung in
Räumen haben wir haben einen
unglaublichen Lehrermangel wir haben
überfüllte Klassen wir sie nicht den
individuellen Schüler und so kann das
ganze System nicht bleiben man muss den
individuellen Schüler sehen gerade auch
in einer Leistungsgesellschaft wo das
Abitur wo der Abschluss den man macht
von Relevanz ist so wie es jetzt ist
kann es nicht bleiben es muss sich
einfach verändern jetzt erlebst du das
ja ganz konkret an deiner Schule kriegst
du denn auch mit inwieweit das im ganzen
Bundesland so problematisch oder bist du
an der besonders schwierigen Schule
vielleicht nein also ich muss sagen für
meine Schule ist läuft vieles sehr gut
ich gehe gerne zur Schule aber ich sage
jeder die Technik fehlt die Lehrer
fehlen der Unterricht ist nicht aktuell
es ist ein Problem was nicht nur ich
habe was nicht nur meine Schule hat
sondern was wirklich aktuell überall in
Hessen wenn ich sogar in ganz
Deutschland vorhanden ist okay das
merken sich die Leute hier im Raum
und wir machen weiter mit Jana ebenfalls
aus Kassel und deine Minute beginnt
jetzt genau hi ich bin Jana schön dass
Ihr alle da sind ich bin 19 Jahre alt
und habe gerade hier in Kassel mein
Abitur gemacht ich bin hier weil die
hessische Landesregierung immer noch
viel zu wenig für den Klimaschutz in
Hessen macht wir haben jetzt eine
hessisches klimages seit März diesen
Jahres darin steht das Hessen bis 2045
erstklima neutralen will das ist viel zu
spät wenn wir uns angucken was wir in
Paris vereinbart haben aber auch was
eben notwendig ist um das 1,5°c noch zu
erreichen hier in Hessen wird am
laufenden Band immer wieder fossile
Infrastruktur ausgebaut das sind
autobahnprojekte aber das ist auch hier
in Kassel ganz konkret der
flughafenkasse Calden in dem immer
wieder Millionen Geld an verschwendet
werden was wir jetzt brauchen ist
endlich eine Wende in Richtung
klimagerechtes Kassen und das für nehme
ich persönlich die Grünen die hier in
der Landesregierung seit acht Jahren
sitzen in Verantwortung die Grünen haben
hier verpasst die notwendigen Schritte
zu gehen eine neugebaute Autobahn bringt
mir auch nichts mehr wenn mein Auto die
Straße runter schwimmt Jana wo merkst du
denn die Klimakrise ganz konkret in
deinem Alltag in Kassel ihr habt das
wahrscheinlich alle noch ganz gute
Erinnerung dass wir hier vor drei Wochen
glaube ich ungefähr so ein riesen
Unwetter hatten das nannte sich super
Zelle da hatten wir irgendwie
Hagelkörner die waren so fünf Zentimeter
groß wir hatten straßenüberstand und
tatsächlich Autos die Straßen
runtergespürt wurden das war glaube ich
so ein Moment wo wir in Kassel hier ganz
konkret gemerkt haben die Klimakrise ist
hier und sie ist eben nicht nur im
globalen Süden wo sie jetzt schon viel
heftiger ist okay vielen Dank
komm deine Minute beginnt genau jetzt
hallo ich bin Torben Epstein 29 Jahre
jung bin gelernter Landwirt und
bewirtschaftet den klassischen
Familienbetrieb mit meinen Eltern und
meiner Freundin mit viel Haltung und
Ackerbau im schönen Hessenland wir sind
momentan vom Aussterben bedroht für Jung
Landwirte und wir kleinen
landwirtschaftlichen Betriebe mit den
steigenden Anforderungen die aus
Gesellschaft und Politik auf uns
zukommen müssen gerade wie jung werden
würde in den jungen 20er Jahren
Millionenbeträge in die Hand nehmen über
mehrere Jahre finanzieren müssen und
hier brauchen wir von der Politik ein
klares Signal ob wir noch Landwirtschaft
und heimische Lebensmittel in den
nächsten Jahren hier haben möchten oder
ob wir die Produktion schrittweise ins
Ausland verlagern wo wir keinerlei
Handhabe mehr haben was dafür Auflagen
bei der Tierhaltung sind oder was für
Pflanzenschutzmittel da eingesetzt
werden und was für Essen dann bei uns
auf dem Teller landet weil da haben wir
alle jeden Tag Kontakt mit ich sag mal
mir Landwirte wir treffen jeden
Verbraucher jeden Tag mehrfach auf dem
Teller das betrifft jeden die wir hier
Landwirtschaft betreiben
und da sind wir jetzt man schweift immer
leicht ab und jetzt bist du gerade mal
29 und hast schon mit riesigen
Investitionen zu tun wo du entscheiden
musst okay nehme ich jetzt Kredite auf
die mich noch Jahrzehnte beschäftigen
werden was sind das für Summen und wofür
musst du die ausgeben neue Stelle sind
im mehreren Millionenbereich
Maschinen die mir dazu brauchen sind
alle im sechsstelligen Bereich wenn dann
Julian wird mit 25 investiert der muss
das mal mindestens bis 45 machen dass er
so irgendwie dadurch kommt er noch
länger und die Zukunft fehlt ja gerade
völlig
also vielen Dank euch allen dass sie
diese sehr verschiedenen Themen
mitgebracht hat an dem man schon
mehr ganz unterschiedlich priorisieren
und treffen kann ihr seid jetzt auch
eine Entscheidung treffen als unser
hessischer kneipenrad worüber soll ich
diesen Sommer recherchieren und
anschließend eine Reportage machen
[Musik]
hier ist es welches von diesen drei
Themen überzeugt euch am meisten ich
denke wir brauchen gerade die
Landwirtschaft es gibt so eine Pyramide
der Bedürfnisse und da ist natürlich
Grundversorgung irgendwie ganz unten
basic meet und alle Themen die haben
Landwirtschaft Umwelt und Verkehr und so
weiter haben ja als in Kern ja Bildung
also ich würde der Frau dir das Klima
Thema präsent hatte
man kann es nicht mehr verleugnen dass
das Klima sich massiv verändert okay
dann stoßen wir kurz darauf an dass das
trotzdem auch besser wird hoffentlich
danke dass du da bist
wer sagt wir sollen uns im Rahmen dieses
Films mit der Bildungsmisere in Hessen
Auseinandersetzen mit lehrerkräftemangel
und damit wie wir immer und alle
Schülerinnen und Schüler besser auf das
Leben nach der Schule vorbereiten können
[Musik]
22 okay das ist schon mal nicht schlecht
aber nur 22 Stunden für immer wer sagt
Jana soll die Kneipen weil gewinnen und
ich soll mehr darüber hinaus finden
warum in Hessen immer noch fossile
Projekte gefördert und Klimaziele außer
Acht gelassen werden
[Musik]
okay 13 Stimmen für Jana Torben wer sagt
diese Reportage soll sich darum drehen
wie wir künftig unsere Versorgung auch
mit regionalen und landwirtschaftlichen
Produkten sicherstellen und wie wir die
Landwirtschaft auch international
wettbewerbsfähig halten
[Musik]
11 für Torben vielen Dank wir haben eine
eindeutige Gewinnerin immer wir sehen
uns noch mal wieder ich komme zu dir und
wir werden uns damit auseinandersetzen
wie wir die Situation von Schülerinnen
und Schülern in Hessen verbessern können
und was Politik dafür machen muss nach
dieser Landtagswahl natürlich werden wir
aber auch die anderen beiden Themen und
Jana und Torben nicht komplett aus den
Augen verlieren wenn ihr wissen wollt
was mit ihren Themen rund um die
Landtagswahl passiert und was man da
ändern könnte und müsste dann folgt uns
auf unseren Kanälen auf tiktok und
Instagram vielen Dank euch dreien vielen
Dank an meinen kneipenrad für die gute
Stimmung hier heute und für euer Foto
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich würde mir für diese Landtagswahl
wünschen dass die Politik uns ernst
nimmt und einfach mit uns ins Gespräch
kommen und zu schauen wie kann man es
anders denken
[Musik]
der kneipenrad hat entschieden ich soll
mich mit der Zukunft der Bildung
beschäftigen denn da geht in Hessen
schon viel zu lange kaum was voran
Schulen sind sanierungsbedürftig
Klassenzimmer platzen aus allen Nähten
und der Lehrermangel sorgt für
Frustration nicht nur bei den
Lehrkräften sondern auch bei
Schülerinnen und Schülern
wir können nicht mehr wir können es so
in dieser Art auch wenn wir wollen uns
aufarbeiten nicht mehr beschulen man
kann den Lehrern nicht noch mehr zumuten
es geht nicht über 100 Jahre ist diese
denkmalgeschützte Grundschule in
Frankfurt alt überall Mängel der
putzbröselt von den Wänden innen ist der
geräuschspiegel aufgrund der miserablen
Akustik der alten Räume so hoch dass
viele Kinder nur noch mit Kopfhörern in
Ruhe arbeiten können letzte Mittel im
Kampf gegen den Lehrermangel sagt
Schulleiterin Anke Bart sind die fünf
Quereinsteiger ja das sind ein paar von
den Sachen die mir bei der Recherche so
begegnet sind was davon kennst du auch
aus deinem Schulalltag einiges auch hier
in Kassel gibt es Schuhe in der regnet
es rein und das wird trotzdem
unterrichtet ähm kann einfach nicht der
Fall sein auch wir haben Quereinsteiger
als Lehrer die wir Schüler oft gar nicht
identifizieren können als Quereinsteiger
sondern wir sehen dann okay ich habe
Vertretung bei Lehrer x und merken das
ist eigentlich gar kein Lehrer ich weiß
gar nicht ob ich den jetzt den Fragen
kann wie geht eigentlich meine
Matheaufgabe die ich gerade lösen muss
sehr viel Ausfall ich habe Tage da habe
ich dritte Viertelstunde frei und erste
zweite fünfte sechste Unterricht und die
Lehrer und Lehrerinnen bei denen ihr
gerade Unterricht habt nimmst du die
auch als gestresst war ja auf jeden Fall
und das ist überhaupt gar kein Vorwurf
den gegenüber sondern wenn man sieht was
die alles leisten da kann man eigentlich
nur gestresst sein Emma jetzt ist es
noch genau ein Jahr bist du Abi machst
was würdest du dir für dieses Jahr noch
wünschen naja zum einen will ich erstmal
gut durchkommen aufs Abi vorbereitet
werden aber auch danach nicht ins kalte
Wasser losgelassen zu werden sondern das
mit mir geredet wird ey was steht dir
danach eigentlich offen ist das eine
Ausbildung duales Studium im Studium und
dann auch was bedeutet das mit Miete
Versicherung Verträge Steuern manche
haben vielleicht schon zu Hause gehört
viele vermutlich aber noch nicht
jetzt ist es ja gar nicht mehr lange bis
zu dieser Landtagswahl was wäre denn
dringendster Wunsch an die Politik ich
würde sagen Lehrerin helfen Unterricht
so zu gestalten dass Schüler Freude an
Schule haben und gerne zur Schule gehen
weil sie als Mensch gesehen werden
[Musik]
wenn ich schon mal hier bin will ich
auch mit Emmas Schulleiter sprechen
[Musik]
hallo hallo
ich habe schon mit ihrer Schülerin Emma
gesprochen und dieser der sie geht hier
sehr gerne zur Schule und trotzdem hat
sie ein paar Sachen wo sie sich wünschen
würde okay das muss ich verbessern also
das Thema eins ist ganz bestimmt die
Raumnot also das das glaube ich schon
wir haben Klassenräume und sonst nichts
man müsste differenzierungsräume haben
man müsste lernen Räume haben die auch
freier zu gestalten sind wo sich junge
Menschen treffen könnten also die
Raumnot ist wirklich unabsehbar und man
merkt es an jedem Tag neu zuletzt musste
die Schule sogar Rheuma an anderen
Standorten anbieten Schülerinnen und
Schüler und das Lehrpersonal laufen also
während eines Schultages jetzt durch
Kassel um ganz normal am Unterricht
teilnehmen zu können was den
Unterrichtsausfall anbelangt ich bin mir
gar nicht so sicher ob das so gravierend
ist also ich glaube schon dass wir eine
ganze Menge tun damit Unterrichtsausfall
minimiert wird da haben wir es natürlich
in hier in Kassel relativ einfach weil
wir
Vertretungslehrkräfte das sind in der
Regel Studenten die übernehmen eine
ganze Reihe von Unterrichtsstunden das
klingt als würden sie das schon so
hinnehmen dass man sagt ja das ist
völlig normal wir haben nicht die
qualifizierten Lehrkräfte sondern dann
greift man zurück auf Studierende die ja
noch nicht voll ausgebildet sind um vor
solchen Klassen zu stehen ja das ist so
ja das ist so das ist auch im Grunde
genommen von der Politik so vorgesehen
weil die Kinder müssen versorgt werden
[Musik]
wenn ein Gymnasien die Lage angespannt
ist wie ist es dann an den
Brennpunktschulen in Offenbach bei
Frankfurt liegt der Anteil der Einwohner
mit Migrationshintergrund bei knapp 64%
und jedes fünfte Kind wächst in Armut
auf hier scheinen die
unterschiedlichsten Kulturen und
Lebensrealitäten Tür an Tür zu wohnen
und ich frage mich wie wirkt sich die
Bildungsmisere auf die Chancengleichheit
aus
[Musik]
ich bin in Murat verabredet er arbeitet
als Streetworker mit Jugendlichen aus
Brennpunkten und will dafür sorgen dass
sie nicht auf die schiefe Bahn geraten
Murat hat selbst auf der Straße gelebt
hat Drogen verkauft und war im Gefängnis
seine Erfahrung packt er heute in seine
Rap-Texte
[Musik]
Brennpunkt die Straße ruft die Straße
ruft Frist oder stirb ist kein
Traumberuf
[Musik]
was für Scheiße hast du denn gemacht als
Jugendlicher mein Vater ist leider früh
verstorben da war ich 15 Jahre alt und
ja also ich habe auch schon viele
Schlägereien und auch sehr sehr viele
schlimme Dinge gemacht was verbinden die
Jugendlichen die du hier triffst mit
Schule ja Schule ist anstrengend Schule
macht keinen Bock Schule ist langweilig
und dann gibt's halt auch Jungs die dann
perspektivlos sind die halt einfach wie
gesagt zur Schule gehen weil die zur
Schule gehen müssen aber ein
Wirklichkeit gar keine Ziele haben es
gibt doch viele Jungs die sich dann auch
ändern die auch merken dass tiktok und
alles andere nicht das Geld von Eis ist
weil es gibt
auch wieder so ein Thema was die Jungs
komplett in die falsche Richtung bringt
also für mich ist es sehr sehr wichtig
den Jugendlichen immer wieder zu sagen
dass es sehr wichtig ist ein
Schulabschluss zu haben weil wenn du
keinen Abschluss hast dann landest du
irgendwann beim Arbeitsamt so und dann
kriegst du dann ein paar Euros kannst ja
nicht mal die neuesten Nike Schuhe damit
leisten geschweige denn mit einem Mädel
ins Kino gehen
also da bist Du glaube ich eher mehr
ausgelacht nichts erreicht zu haben als
wie du was erreicht hast und was bieten
kannst
und wie blickt diese Generation mit der
du so viel zu tun hast auf die Politik
Politik ist für die komplett egal also
ich habe Unterschriften sammeln lassen
und damit der Bolzplatz saniert wird da
wird uns dann irgendwann Versprechen
gegeben also da kam der Bürgermeister da
hieß es ja der das wird sowieso alles
umgebaut und dann wird es auch saniert
und so da wurde halt Versprechen gegeben
und es wird nicht eingehalten was macht
das mit den Jugendlichen das natürlich
die sind dann schon so enttäuscht auf
jeden Fall man holt sie einfach nicht ab
man verliert einfach Wähler also man
muss die Jugendlichen von Anfang an
schon gerade in der Schule finde ich
sollte man das auch machen dass man den
auch die Parteien vor Augen hält oder
auch Demokratie vor Augen hält also das
hat man ja gesehen dass sehr viele nicht
mehr wählen gegangen sind ja so und das
finde ich sehr sehr schade
[Musik]
Murat nimmt mich mit zum Boxclub Nord
end dort dürfen die Kinder nur
mittrainieren wenn die Noten stimmen wer
eine 4 auf dem Zeugnis hat muss vor dem
Training in die Club eigene Nachhilfe
die ehrenamtlich von den Coaches
übernommen wird
[Musik]
danke dass ich hier sein darf warum sind
die Kids die jetzt hier bei dir im
Klassenzimmer sitzen überhaupt hier der
Boxclub bitte denn eine Möglichkeit halt
neben den Sport dass die Schule da nicht
Stich gelassen werden deswegen versuche
ich den zu helfen und klar zu machen
dass Schule auch sehr wichtig ist
was machst du gerade
[Musik]
rationale Zahlen ja noch nicht so viel
Spaß
aber hilft wahrscheinlich also glaubst
du du lernst in der Schule was was du
für spätere Leben noch brauchst ja also
man braucht ja auch für später für
Arbeit Ausbildung alles okay
und dann gehen wir jetzt in die Halle
[Musik]
giordana kam mit ihrer Familie aus
Rumänien hier im Boxclub hat sie
sozialen Anschluss gefunden heute ist
sie amtierende hessenmeisterin der
Frauen bis 52 Kilo und ein großes
Vorbild für Reimann der selbst auch
Boxer werden will
[Musik]
Alter Raimund ich schwitze schon vom
zugucken bist du wie oft bist du hier
wie auf trainierst du
manchmal zweimal am Tag aber jeden Tag
so 18 Uhr jeden Tag krass das heißt du
bist manchmal öfter hier jetzt in der
Schule
ja und unterstützen sie dich dabei ja
manchmal die sind auch zum Kämpfen
gekommen wirklich stark das heißt sie
interessieren sich schon dafür was du
aus in deiner Freizeit machst jetzt
würde ja manch einer sagen wenn man
Boxer werden will muss man gar nicht zur
Schule gehen
eigentlich muss man gehen aber
manche wollen nicht
Wolfgang malik ist der Gründer des
Boxclubs und seit über 40 Jahren in der
Offenbacher Jugendarbeit aktiv er war
derjenige der Murat damals von der
Straße geholt hat heute arbeiten sie
zusammen
also ich habe jetzt den Eindruck
gewonnen dass ihr Sachen ausgleicht die
das Schulsystem selbst gar nicht leisten
kann dass ich die Situation bei
Jugendlichen die aus eher sehr prekären
Familiensituationen kommen das ist die
Pandemie auch nochmal verschärft hat das
ganze Homeschooling und so es gibt es
gibt viele Kinder und Jugendliche die
haben daheim überhaupt nicht die
Möglichkeiten gehabt zu lernen und so
und das sind auch viele abgespielt und
wir haben das Ziel dass man die
Jugendliche wieder in die Schule
einfädelt damit ich den Sinn der Schule
auch erkennen ne das heißt aber übers
Boxen gewinnt und motiviert ist die
Brücke weil die Jugendliche die wir
erreichen wollen die kriegt sie nicht
mit Tischtennis ja und was was ist an
Boxen reizvoller als im Schulunterricht
die geben Halt Gas und sie sind halt
auch als Ausgleich irgendwo ne also das
bestätigt die Jungs dann halt natürlich
auch die Mädels was haben diese
Jugendlichen mit den ihr hier arbeitet
für Perspektiven im Vergleich zu anderen
Jugendlichen in Deutschland
festhalten die haben nur schwere das ist
so die brauchen sehr viel mehr
Unterstützung weil es ist auch oft so
dass im Elternhaus wenig Unterstützung
nicht aus Bösartigkeit fallen die Eltern
selber ja also damit auch Probleme haben
was haben die Jugendlichen hier für ein
Bezug zu Politik wenn überhaupt
irgendeinen es ist natürlich schon so
dass junge Leute und auch Erwachsene
einfache Antworten suchen so und es gibt
viele Leute auch aus in die
krankenmilieu die aus eher konservativen
und Nationalitäten kommen
die neigen zu AFD weil die bieten genau
das weil sie wollen klare Kante zu sagen
was los ist die Politik treiben und so
und wir regeln das für euch und es
stimmt gar nicht dass man was gegen
Migranten haben und dann müssen wir
dringend gegen steuern oder dass ich
gehört habe von einem marokkanischen
älteren Herr hat gesagt eure ganze
Geschichte weil sie einfach nicht
informiert sind und das ist der Punkt
das müssen wir trinken auf dem Schirm
haben weil die vitalien ja auch in
Offenbach ihre blaue Luftballons
in Offenbach wo fast zwei Drittel der
Menschen Migrationshintergrund haben kam
die AFD bei der letzten Landtagswahl auf
13,4 Prozent ich bin auf dem Weg nach
Wiesbaden in die Landeshauptstadt um die
Verantwortlichen damit zu konfrontieren
inwieweit das Schulsystem wirklich alle
Menschen im Land mitnimmt und fördert
Alexander Lorz ist der amtierende
Kultusminister von Hessen er besucht
heute einen Sommerferien nachhilfecamp
in der Werner-von-Siemens-Schule
[Musik]
hallo ich habe mich gefragt es sind
große Ferien und trotzdem seid ihr sind
sie hier drin und machen Nachhilfe ist
das jetzt was Gutes oder was schlecht
das ist gut weil also es ist eine
Unterstützung weil durch Corona sind
viele Sachen auf der Strecke geblieben
und da nehmen wir uns einfach jetzt noch
mal die Zeit gerade in den Ferien
vormittags das ist ja auch ganz gut um
das nachzuarbeiten und kann einen guten
Gewissens ins neue Schuljahr starten ich
war auch alle anderen gym
nasium und da fein ständig Stunden aus
ist das was ihr auch mal erlebt habt ja
wir hatten Vertretung mal was einfach
Schüler aus den älteren Klassen was
eigentlich auch ganz cool war aber das
ist ja schon krass nur dass man dann
älteren Schüler auf einmal vorgesetzt
bekommt also das erinnere ich aus meiner
Schulzeit nicht da gab es zumindest
immer irgendwie ein Lehrer der versucht
hat die Stunde zu schmeißen was wollt
ihr denn machen nach der Schule wisst
ihr das schon ja Architektur und
Bauzeichnerin
und ja dafür brauche ich mein Abitur
dann beides auch richtig anspruchsvolle
Jobs und habt ihr denn das Gefühl dass
Schule euch darauf gut vorbereitet also
uns wurde immer gesagt man sollte ein
Ziel vor Augen haben bevor man das
Abitur macht als ich gesagt habe ich
hier Fluglotse werden ich habe ein Ziel
vor Augen da habe ich auch die voll
Unterstützung bekommen
[Musik]
schon cool noch mal eine Schule zu sehen
in der ist eigentlich ziemlich gut läuft
die Lehrer sind hier nicht gestresst
sondern engagiert und können durch
dieses Nachhilfe Camp auch einzeln auf
jeden Schüler jede Schülerin eingehen er
überrascht es nicht dass der
Kultusminister natürlich diese Schule
auswählt um sich im Wahlkampf zu zeigen
[Musik]
hätten sie das gerade noch lösen ich
denke gerade darüber nach
ich hatte ich hatte ja Mathe
Leistungskurse
Mathematiker viele ist wie gesagt 40
Jahre her das kommt ja alles bekannt vor
aber ich glaube bräuchte eine Anleitung
Sie haben das nie wieder im Leben
gebraucht was sie in der Schule gewesen
jetzt war ich im Land unterwegs und habe
ein ganz unterschiedlichen Schulen
Eindrücke gesammelt von einem Gymnasium
in Kassel bis hin zu einer eher so ein
Brennpunkt Umgebung in Offenbach und da
waren die Schülerinnen und Schüler nicht
alle so glücklich die haben zum Teil
gesagt sie leiden extrem unter
Lehrermangel unter sanierungsbedürftigen
Schulen dramatisieren die Situation dann
also
sozusagen auseinanderhalten wir haben
36.000 Kinder und Jugendliche ohne
deutsche Muttersprache im Bildungssystem
das sind natürlich alles
Belastungsfaktoren der Fach bestimmte
Mangel der uns in allen Branchen
beschäftigt natürlich beschäftigt er uns
auch in lehrkräftebereich das sage ich
aber auch gerade der jungen Generation
ihr habt Chancen wie eigentlich keine
Generation vor euch hat es auch ein
bisschen was mit dem Fachkräftemangel zu
tun ja die jungen Menschen werden
wahnsinnig gesucht wie erklären Sie sich
das oder wie finden sie das wenn ich ihn
erzähle dass eine Gymnasiastin aus
Kassel mit einem akademischen Elternhaus
genauso verdrossen auf diese
Landtagswahl guckt wie Jungs Mädels mit
echt schwierigerem Hintergrund aus
Offenbach und die sich überlegen ob
überhaupt eine der etablierten Parteien
die richtige für Sie ist oder ob sie
sich doch sich die AFD mal näher
angucken müssen ja das ist natürlich
etwas was uns alle
besorgen muss das ist völlig glaube auch
kein Patentrezept dafür gefunden haben
da muss man auch so ehrlich sein das ist
eine Herausforderung an alle
demokratischen Parteien also es gibt
eigentlich keinen Grund Angst vor der
Zukunft zu haben und ähm ich glaube da
wird einfach auch sehr viel geführt weil
das irgendwie schick ist ähm
Herausforderungen
tun ich habe auch wirklich Jugendliche
getroffen die sagen boah
Preissteigerungen Klimawandel es ist
Krieg auf unserem Kontinent die Sorgen
sagen sie die sind ungegründet nein die
Sorgen sind keineswegs unbegründet aber
es ist auch nicht so als vorherige
Generation keine Sorgen gehabt hätten
natürlich ist das furchtbar was im
mussten geschieht und deswegen müssen
wir auch politisch mit einem Phänomen
Krieg entsprechend umgehen aber es ist
trotzdem nichts jetzt sage ähm da muss
jetzt die Generation in Deutschland
Angst davor haben das ist alles um sie
herum zusammenbrechen
also der Minister hat ja im Grunde
gesagt frühere Generationen hatten auch
schon Probleme und es sei alles gar
nicht so dramatisch wie aber viele
Schülerinnen und Schüler das heute
empfinden macht er sich damit nicht ein
bisschen zu einfach
[Musik]
Emma und ihre Freunde stehen genau an
der Schwelle zum Erwachsenwerden diese
Generation wird in Zukunft Verantwortung
übernehmen wollen und müssen dabei ist
Bildung der Schlüssel zum Erfolg wie gut
hat das Schulsystem sie auf die
kommenden Herausforderungen vorbereitet
[Musik]
ihr werdet ja von Medien aber auch
Politik gerne mal so als die
corona-generation die krisengeneration
bezeichnet ist das ein Klischee oder ist
da was dran also ich finde auf jeden
Fall schon dass sowas dran ist zumal
sich ja durch die Medien immer diese
schlechten Nachrichten immer wieder
häufen ob das jetzt die corona-krise ist
oder die Ukraine das passt halt
dauerhaft auf einen ein und
das Problem ist auf das ich persönlich
auch teilweise dann nicht damit
klarkommen ich habe da so ein druck baut
sich auch auf z.B wenn ich den
Klimawandel habe dass ich da auch was
tun muss was schaffen muss und mir fällt
es schwer in dem Moment dann einfach mal
abzuschalten das heißt du sitzt in der
Schule wo gerade der Druck aufsteigt
weil bald Abiturprüfungen sind und
denkst gleichzeitig an die Welt da
draußen Zitat von den Lehrer z.B an der
meinte ich sehe genau die Leute die
Abitur hier schaffen und ich sie die
Leute die das Abitur auf jeden Fall
nicht schaffen werden
hier diesen Druck noch verstärken
anstatt das Schule versucht euch solche
großen Ängste und Sorgen noch irgendwie
zu nehmen oder gibt es das schon auch
also
wir haben unter anderem Sozialpädagogen
aber die sind halt total rar wir haben
jetzt an der Schule glaube ich eine
Person die das macht einmal du bist ja
Schülersprecherin das heißt du
vertrittst ja quasi politisch auch eine
Schülerschaft die genau das erlebt hat
was versucht ihr denn euren Lehrern der
Schulleitung deutlich zu machen was ihr
jetzt für andere Bedürfnisse habt als
vielleicht die nicht corona-generation
es kann nicht sein dass man in die
Schule geht und Druck verspürt die man
standhalten muss das ist und das System
Schule was nicht funktioniert das
funktioniert nicht für den 5 Klasse für
die 12 Klasse funktioniert das genauso
wenig wenn ich selbst zu mir sage ich
möchte gut sind in der Schule dann gehe
ich klar anders in die Schule aber gebe
mir selbst auch den Druck und offen
gesprochen den Druck gehen nicht mehr
selbst gebe der schon schwierig zu
handeln und sobald man in dem System
nicht mehr funktioniert hat man verloren
wer im System nicht funktioniert hat
verloren doch das ganze System ist im
Moment nah am Kollaps veraltete
Lehrpläne zu viel Druck fehlende
Lehrkräfte zu wenig Räume Bildung ist
Ländersache und die Politik hat da ihre
Hausaufgaben viele Jahre nicht richtig
gemacht setzen sechs würden viele
Schülerinnen und Schüler sagen das Thema
Bildung hat bei der kneipenwald klar
gewonnen und auch das ZDF Politbarometer
zu Landtagswahl zeigt Bildung ist Thema
Nummer eins in Hessen
der Druck der auf der jungen Generation
lastet ist enorm hoch und Schule so wie
sie jetzt ist es nicht dafür gemacht all
diese Herausforderungen zu meistern und
da kommt Politik ins Spiel diese
Landtagswahl hier wäre eine Chance aus
Hessen heraus Impulse zu setzen die dann
auf Bundesebene fortgesetzt werden aber
nach dieser Reise auf die der kneipenrat
hat mich geschickt hat habe ich noch
nicht das Gefühl dass die Politik das
wirklich verstanden hat
[Musik]